[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact water skippers are found in
ponds lakes streams and oceans all
across the northern hemisphere they're
known by many different names ponds
Striders water skaters Jesus bugs just
to name a few they might resemble
spiders but they're classified in the
Jared I family that contains about 1,700
species water skippers are fun to watch
because of their unique ability to walk
and scamper on the surface of the water
without ever breaking through they're
able to do this because the ends of
their feet contain thousands of
microscopic hairs that trap air giving
them amazing buoyancy the water skippers
legs are so buoyant they can support 15
times their own weight keeping them
floating high and dry through rainstorms
waves and river rapids water skippers
try to avoid humans but they do hunt and
eat other bugs such as mosquito larvae
that live within their water kingdom but
if a bug falls in their pond they
quickly locate their prey by reading the
Whipple's on the water's surface with
their legs then using their middle legs
like paddles they scurry over the pond
to find their dinner have you ever
wished that you could walk on water and
the Bible talks about two individuals
that had that experience stay with his
friends were going to learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
my name is john ross and past that i may
start the program with prayer do you
father once again we are grateful that
we have this opportunity to open your
word and study we ask your blessing upon
our program this evening and we pray
that the Spirit of God our minds and
those who are listening wherever they
might be lead us into a clearer
understanding what the Bible says for we
asses in Jesus name Amen
amen well past that I open the program
talking about these little bugs that run
all over the place little water the
rather interesting there's another
animal that comes to mind down in Costa
Rica they have lizards that run across
the water through a column of Jesus
that's right quite something does not
the scientific name do they had did they
have water bugs in South Africa they did
I'm not sure the kind but I remember
them yeah yeah because they're not
everywhere in the southern hemisphere's
like a small the northern hemisphere
yeah and I remember when I lived in the
mountains in that a cave I had a pool of
water right outside the cave and plenty
of spare time I'd watch them for hours
and and it's kind of fascinating there
the little antics on the water
you know if we try and walk on water it
doesn't always work so well mm-hmm but
the Bible talks about a couple of
individuals that did walk on water and I
think many of our friends know the story
Jesus sent the disciples across the Sea
of Galilee as he was dismissing this
crowd they were trying to make him King
and he was sending them off he told the
disciples cross the sea I'll catch up
with you and they thought he'd come in
another boat well in the middle of the
night they were stuck out there the wind
was against them and they were making no
progress out in the middle of the sea
and it's nighttime and they see this
phantom apparition coming towards him on
the water and you know they they all
cried out in fear and Jesus said don't
be afraid it's me and Peter who was
always the first one to say anything he
said lord if it's you then bid me to
walk to you on the water
Jesus had come Peter got out of the boat
and he started walking towards Christ on
the water and he was doing you know be
impossible but then he took his eyes off
of Christ maybe to see if his friends
were catching it on video when he took
his eyes off Christ he then noticed the
wind and the waves and thought what am i
doing out here in the middle of the dark
ocean and his faith began to sink and he
began to sink and just before he went
under he turned back to Jesus and said
lord save me one of the shortest prayers
in the Bible Jesus grabbed him by the
hand and pulled him back up again and
led him back to the boat so they walked
on the water and I think one of the
lessons in this story is very important
for every Christian walking on water is
normally impossible but you could do it
if you keep your eyes on Jesus living a
holy life in this wicked world under
normal conditions it would be impossible
but if you keep your eyes on Jesus you
can do it if you call out when you start
to sink keep your eyes fixed on him do
not live by sight looking at the wind
and the waves live by faith looking unto
Jesus tells us in Hebrews chapter 12 the
way that we can succeed it says fixing
your eyes on Jesus we can lay aside the
sin and the weights it's so easily
ensnare us and friends God is calling
all of us to repent of our sins he
promises through his sacrifice to have
myrrh
see to forgive our sins and then he
gives us power to live new lives old
things are passed away all things are
made new you become a new creature he
can give you victory over whatever your
temptations habits and besetting sins
are don't believe some of the modern
stories that Jesus just forgives us and
we go on continuing to sin the way we
always did Christians are called to a
new kind of living and you can be a new
creature we have a book don't let the
title scare you it will encourage you
about how you can live a miraculous life
the book is called is it possible to
live without sinning and as pastor Doug
said you need to get the book it's worth
reading and you'll find it very
encouraging Jesus said with man it might
be impossible but with God all things
are possible so get the book I think
you'll enjoy it if you'd like to receive
a free copy of the book the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
that is a resource phone line and we'll
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks again just after the book
is it possible to live without sinning
again one more time here's the resource
number 800 eight three five six seven
four seven and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven that's 800 four six 372 97
well we're ready to go to our first
caller this evening and we have a caller
from Florida with a Kris listening from
Lady Lake Chris welcome to the program
thank you Pastor good evening evening
good evening I can really I will try to
make it quick and it's about prophecy
from Ezekiel Ezekiel 38 and 18 through
23 all right let's go there a zekiel
chapter 38 it says it'll come to pass at
that time when God comes against the
land of Israel says the Lord God that
I'll show my fury in my face in my
jealousy okay it's a prophecy about Gog
and Magog and what is your question
about that because it takes quite a
while to read all this the god unball so
mad dog what do you think what countries
there will be two that will actually eat
rayul well you first heard here
reference to God and I think it's Jen
chapter 10 these were some of the
ancient enemies of God's people when you
get to Revelation chapter 20 I believe
it is where it says that Satan calls
together Gog and may God the word Magog
in the ancient language simply means
from the matrix of Gog so it's saying
God and the children of God it's kind of
like Babylon and the daughters of
Babylon it's not talking about some
people say God can make Agra Russia and
China and there's really no scripture to
support that Gog and Magog were they
were enemies of God's people in the time
of Israel there were real enemies in
Revelation it's symbolic for the enemies
of God throughout the ages all the
wicked the names in Revelation are all
symbolic yeah okay okay and one more
thing it's very related to it the
subject from Zechariah 14 and verse 16
and 17 it says that all nations will be
required when the King comes name to
Jesus they will be required to observe
the Feast of Tabernacles yeah when it
talks about the Feast of Tabernacles
there in Zechariah I think it's
basically saying they're all going to
remember the way God saved them during
the end the Feast of Tabernacles was to
remind them about the way God saved them
from Egypt and provided for them as they
tabernacled in the wilderness the
Zechariah is basically saying in this
prophecy that everybody then is going to
be remembering how God saved them and
provided them in its and the exodus was
an illustration of that the Zechariah
zekiel you're picking on two of the two
of the deepest books Chris and but your
your deep thinker I can tell hope that
helps a little bit
next one that we have is Bill listening
from Illinois bill welcome to the
program I ask you John how are you
deceive me doing great thanks for
calling okay my question is this I just
got finished reading king of the first
book of kings okay and I want to know
the facts about were Solomon built the
temple and then he moved to our for the
College
temple and I want to know it says I
don't remember the exact verse but it
says that the only thing in the ark were
the two tables of stone and I'm reading
this from the King James Version if that
helps any but my question is what
happened to the book of the law that
Moses wrote and then also what happened
to the jar that they had the manna in
for I guess remembering how Jesus took
care of them in the wilderness yes and
Aaron's rod good question let me let me
see what I can do about that you'll
remember that before the time of David
in the book of Samuel and I believe it's
First Samuel the Ark was captured by the
Philistines and it's very possible that
during that time well there's two things
that happened the Ark was captured by
the Philistines and then when the ark
came back to the Land of Israel I think
it was the men of jabish Gilead looked
in the Ark and there was a plague but
many of them died from that so either
the Philistines or the people of jabish
Gilead they reached in and they took out
the rod of Aaron and the pot of manna
now as far as the law of Moses they
still had the book of the law because in
pastor Ross might help me read this but
when Josiah had them searching the
sanctuary they found the book of the law
written by Moses we believe this is the
Torah and they read it too it may even
be just the book of Deuteronomy they
read it to Joe Josiah and he cried that
was not in the ark the book of the law
was in a pocket on the outside of the
Ark
only the Ten Commandments the rod of
Aaron and the pot of manna were on the
inside of the ark during the wilderness
wanderings when the ark was captured by
the Philistines either they or the
people of jabish Gilead must have
removed it it does not say but they
probably looked in the ark because I
think the Philistines they put an
offering back in the Ark didn't they
they put like five golden mice or
something so they were opening up the
ark they didn't have the same scruples
about that that the Israelites did hey
thank you very much
Tyler hope that helps a little bit and
for your question or rather bill the
virtue referring to pass sadeghi second
Chronicles
34:14 that talks about them he'll kya
the priest finding the book of the law
yeah
written by Moses in the temple did you
know that Noah was present at the birth
of Abraham okay maybe he wasn't in the
room but he was alive and probably
telling stories about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of Revelation Bible
history calm is a free resource where
you can explore major Bible events and
characters enhance your knowledge of the
Bible and draw closer to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History Tom Mix
one of that we have a Zayn listening
from we've got California Zayn welcome
to the program Colton yes I had a
question because I've been trying to get
closer to God but I have this thing I've
always not understood completely does
the Holy Spirit use guilt to guide
people it's something I've always been
confused by and kind of worried about
well don't worry
Jesus doesn't want you to live in fear
the verse in the Bible where Jesus talks
about the Holy Spirit it says he comes
not only to comfort but to convict he
the Spirit of Truth when he's come he
will convict the world of
unrighteousness so one of the jobs of
the Holy Spirit is to bring conviction
when God poured out the Holy Spirit Zain
in Acts chapter 2 you'll notice that as
Peter preached and said you're guilty of
betraying the Messiah it says they were
pricked in their hearts and that's just
a figure of speech we're saying they
were deeply convicted and they said what
do we do well God didn't leave them in a
state of guilt he said repent and you'll
be forgiven and God will give you the
Holy Spirit
so that's sermon and their conviction
that repentance was a gift of the Holy
Spirit and do you have that John 15:26
you don't read that please but when the
comforter comes whom I will send for the
father even the Spirit of Truth which
precedes from the Father he shall
testify of me and then it goes on to say
that the work of the Holy Spirit is to
bring conviction of unrighteousness John
15:26 and onwards people obviously that
would be the same sensation as guilt
there's a conviction there's a remorse
but God doesn't want to leave you
there the book of James says humble
yourself in the sight of God and He will
lift you up Jesus wants us to repent of
our sins that comes through conviction
and some people call that guilt we feel
guilty for our sins but you don't want
to have the kind of repentance where
Judas repented he went out and hung
himself
Peter repented he went in wept and Jesus
forgave him our guilt shouldn't does
leave us beating ourselves up it should
lead us to repentance then reform in a
new life forgiveness is that helping
Zayn does that make sense yeah very good
well thank you very much and you will
enjoy the book we're offering tonight
the title again sometimes intimidates
people but it's a great book it's called
is it possible to live without sinning
and the number to call if you'd like to
receive that book he's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and again asked for the book is it
possible to live without sinning we've
got Charles listening in Florida Charles
welcome to the program thank you um my
question is Oh actually before that was
my question the Lance Lance writers that
you were talking about yeah I used to
play with a lot back in the country of
uh back in hills at Tennessee let me ask
it did you ever get bit by one no
actually I did yeah they've most of them
don't bite but I read online and getting
my amazing fact ready that some of them
do isn't they're not dangerous
some of them will poke you anyway going
I was just curious about the Tennessee a
variety and your question but my
question is well I want to live more
holy for Christ I want to be able to do
more you know doing his will like
helping the homeless you know visit the
sick that kind of thing but but my funds
are not really there to help in in the
way that I want to so and my question is
how will I know when I'm fully ready for
when Christ comes because I want to be
more holy for him well it sounds like
you want to do more service now you're
not saved by doing service right you
want to do this service because you love
the Lord and you are saved exactly you
know if you if you're not able to serve
because you know by donations a lot of
churches have programs where they need
people that just come and volunteer
their time
where you can help feed that you know
they have food lines where they need
people to serve the food you know in our
church we take we dispense literature to
the homeless and people that are in need
we dispense clothing and food and and
practical winter supplies the people who
are helping us don't necessarily need to
have money but they're giving their time
you might check with some of the good
churches in your community and find out
how you can volunteer that sounds good
also what about as far as like like like
funds as far as the same thing I
actually have student loans so I mean if
Christ comes before those are paid off
is that going to affect me or is
economic
well you're not you're definitely not
being saved by being out of debt if God
only saves those that have no debt and
then a lot of people aren't going to
make it that otherwise would love to be
Christians you know what hey you're the
first Charles you're the first he's
gonna hear this I wrote a book called
deliverance from debt it's got a lot of
encouragement in it and I will send you
a free copy that just I saw it up on the
publishers desk last night it's
brand-new it's based on a message I
shared a couple of months ago
deliverance from debt will send you a
free copy if you call the resource line
the number to call again is just simply
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and you can ask for the new
book entitled deliverance from debt 808
three five six seven four seven
we've got Lawrence listening from New
York Lawrence Welk to the program hello
sir greetings greetings thank you for
calling I'm so happy that you took my
call how can we help you tonight okay a
question I was wondering today when we
desert a message in his church about
Matthew 24 and verse 35 24 the far as he
is trying to trap Jesus with a question
and Jesus was conquering them and then I
did was a point here um
she's asked them a question
and and I'm polling the answer he says
how come DF is either supposed to be the
rules who is Jesus Jesus son of David
there well Jesus calls it that jesus is
the son of David and yet called Jesus
Lord yeah the Lord said unto my lord sit
at my right hand until I make the
enemies a footstool references like that
that's in Luke 20 verse 42 yeah
beautiful so we kind of figure out how
was it possible that jesus is the son of
David and at the same time David is
calling alone well you might also ask
when Mary had her prayer and she's
basically saying you know that I should
be the mother of my lord and so it's not
just that David realized that Jesus his
son was ultimately he was an ancestor of
David but he was a messiah God came
through man in the Incarnation yeah I
think that it's just telling us that doe
yeah in the discussion that Jesus had
with the Pharisees the religious leaders
they were refusing to acknowledge that
Jesus was anything more than just a man
and I think in Christ's discussion with
him and in quoting David quoting from
the Psalms he was trying to help them
understand that the Lord or the Christ
was more than just the physical son of
David but he also is the son of God and
after Jesus said this to them Matthew 22
verse 46 says and no man was able to
answer him a word so I think the point
was made that the Christ was more than
just the son of David he was also the
son of God right and Jesus in his
passage he's quoting from Psalms 110
verse 1 where he says the Lord said unto
my lord sit at my right hand until I
make your enemies your footstool and
your you know the book of Matthew starts
by making the point that Jesus is the
Son of David and yet he is the Messiah
mm-hmm and so it's a very important
point thank you for your question
Lawrence
within the pages of the Bible stories of
great heroes heroes of great deeds great
love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 like the myth of Atlantis
and they've tried to mix it with the
Bible and say well when God started
creating our world it was because the
prior world had been destroyed by the
waters and and we're just reading about
the recreation of that world after this
flood before the time of Noah that what
you're talking about yeah well yeah but
before yeah yeah before even creation
creation that's a theory that just a
handful of people have put out there's
nothing in the Bible that supports prior
to Genesis that there was a another
flood all right yeah I've heard it but a
good question you know the Bible tells
us that God when he flooded the world
and he told Noah I'll put the rainbow in
the sky is a promise that I will never
do it again well he was pretty clear
that was the first time and it was the
last time he didn't say this is the
second time
flooded the world right yeah I think
that was it yeah that was the first
flood and next time it says he's
destroying the world not with water but
with fire that second Peter chapter 3
thank you appreciate your call e
we've got Debra listening in Tennessee
Debra welcome to the program
hello pastors good evening evening
thanks for calling I have a question I
wanted to ask you for a long time in
revelation 22 two words talking about
the leaves of the tree were for the
healing of Nations I read in the
writings of another author that that
meant to leave the pages of the Bible
were the leads do you know anything
about that you know I don't know that
I've heard that when it says that you
see the tree of life is a real tree it's
not a symbolic tree and it says that
there there are 12 different kinds of
fruit 12 times a year and the the leaves
of the tree are for the healing of the
nation's that is a quote and pastor Ross
might help me I think it's in the last
chapter of Ezekiel that says that all
around where the water flows from the
temple everything where the water flows
will live and the leaves of the tree
will be for medicine it's very similar
to what you find in Revelation
yeah that's Ezekiel chapter 47 verse 12
I think God is just telling us that
every part of the tree the fruit the
leaves give life in healing now I've
heard this given a couple of ways
Deborah one theory was that right now in
the world all the nations are divided by
our governments our races our languages
in heaven we'll all speak the same
language there'll be no government or
racial barriers as we all gather under
that magnificent tree of life all the
barriers and all the things that
separate us are going to be healed and
so the being under the leaves are a
symbol for that and when it says the
tree of life the Bible is called a tree
of life and the leaves of the pages of
the Bible are healing I've heard that
metaphor before but I don't think that's
supposed to eclipse the truth that
they're really built will
the leaves on the tree of life that may
have some special powers because you
find it both in Ezekiel and repeated in
Revelation hey we really appreciate that
Debra thank you for calling several
first-time callers we invite you to give
us more calls we love hearing from you
I'm stalling a little bit now because 19
seconds we're taking our mid time break
and I don't want to start and stop a new
question don't go away friends the best
part of the program is yet to come and
we're gonna have more Bible questions
when we come back jot down amazing facts
dot o-r-g and you can be blessed by this
ministry all week long coming back in
just a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven a mutiny that moved
to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
four life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm or call one
eight hundred five three eight seven two
seven five one to know God's plan for
our world and solutions for your life's
challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more prefer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 805 three eight seven
two seven five written by the hand of
God and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com every bible
question you have answered moves you one
step closer to the fullness of god's
will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
my name is shawn ross and we're ready to
go back to the phone lines we've got
Robert listening in Walla Walla
Washington Robert welcome to the program
nice I pastor Doug hi and your question
tonight yeah I was I know you've got the
question in front of you but could I
change my question what depends on what
you change it to we may not know the
answer so go ahead take a stab at it
okay it's John chapter 20 verse 17 where
Jesus is going to be resurrect I mean
he's going to up to go up to heaven yeah
um and he tells Mary do not cling to me
for I have not yet ascended to my father
but go to my brethren and tell them I'm
sending to my father and your father to
my god and your God does Jesus have a
God when Christ was
as a man the Bible says that he assumed
all the ways that man should approach
God so that we could associate and
understand and Jesus prayed why would
Jesus need to pray if he if he had his
divinity when Christ was a man he did
not have all knowledge swirling around
in his head
I mean just think about it for a minute
if he's born as a baby when he came out
did he come out talking no we had to
learn did he come out walking he had to
learn he had to get potty-trained by
Mary like other children he was entirely
human because he laid aside his divinity
so before his ascension he's basically
telling Mary and the disciples he says
I'm going to my father when I taught you
to pray our Father in Heaven he said our
Father and when he prayed he said my
father you know Christ always gave us an
example of how to approach God do you
think do you think Jesus is God the Son
you know mm-hmm yeah so I believe that
too so I think that you're looking at
his response here before his ascension
you know he's basically saying go tell
the Brethren I'm going to the God that
I've been telling you about my god that
I've been teaching you about there are
many different gods in the world that
people worshiped that's true now you
know I've got a book I'll be happy to
send you we've got that new book on the
Trinity where it talks about the
divinity of Christ I don't know if we
answer this person that's a good it's a
good verse alright so if you'd like to
see the book it's called the Trinity is
a biblical and it deals with this whole
idea about the Godhead and what the
Bible teaches we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and ask the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask the book on the Trinity just
called the Trinity is it biblical next
caller that they have is Judy listening
from New York Judy welcome to the
program how you doing I'm doing very
well my question is regarding perfectly
coming from Matthew 5 verse 14 and I
call be perfect as in some of the
enhancement is perfect how
we be perfect when as a chance Moreno
I've always heard Norman is perfect no
one is perfect
well you know I think the key to
understanding this verse is if you look
at what he says in Luke he says be
therefore merciful just as your father
in heaven is merciful now which would
you find easier being perfect or being
merciful merciful all right so when you
look at Matthew chapter 5 he's talking
about how to relate to your brethren
notice you go to verse 43 love your
neighbor love your enemies bless those
who curse you if you only do good to
those that do good to you he's talking
about loving your brother so when he
says therefore be perfect as your father
in heaven is perfect
keep in mind you read that same passage
in Luke and it's same B therefore
merciful and that's Luke 636 B therefore
merciful God wants us to have perfect
love and mercy with our brethren he's
not asking us to be stainless steel
robots so when you look in the Bible and
you read about people like Peter do you
believe Peter is gonna be saved yes okay
well did there was Peter a very
interesting character yes he mean you
know did a lot of stumbling he spoke
before he thought even the Apostle Paul
and David and you look at the characters
that ended up becoming heroes of faith
in the Bible and most of us would not
describe them as perfect I mean the ones
I worry about if people like Daniel seem
pretty perfect Elijah
may be Joseph there's no record of their
sins well Joker Joseph did toy with his
brothers a little bit but the fact that
they made it makes me believe I can make
it because the Bible says Elijah was a
man subject to the same passions as you
and me and yet he prayed and the you
know the heavens stopped raining and
then it started raining then fire came
down and these are real people like you
and me and God gave them his spirit and
he gave them this perfect love and mercy
and we can have that okay thank you very
much for the clarity thank you and you
will enjoy the book is it possible to
live without sinning it talks about this
subject the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again just ask to the
book a free offer for the sea
is it possible to live without sinning
we have a cola calling for the first
time from Massachusetts I believe it's
Federer welcome to the program hi how's
it going
doing good thank you for calling my
first time you know actually getting to
meet you so I'm thrilled they listen to
you since I was 12 years old Wow well
thank you for calling and what's your
question tonight well truth be told I've
watched your video the richest caveman
and I gave me some inspiration but has
to my question would be how is it that I
would come to find my purpose you know
what what you know what it is that the
Lord wants me to do you know for the
rest of my life good question now before
we disconnect I want to tell you right
up that we have a book we want to send
you called discovering the will of God
it basically is a book written about
your question how do you know God's will
for your life
first of all do what lies closest to
hand with all of your might if you say
Lord I want you to tell me what my life
is supposed to be and God doesn't always
lay out the whole blueprint
he usually shines the light on your next
two or three steps mm-hmm
so say Lord show me the next two or
three steps it might be now do you mind
my asking how old you are you said
you've been listening since you were 12
I'm 22 years old okay you're a young man
you're yeah I've got guitar strings
older than you on my guitar so yours
you're still in the beginning continue
your education find out what what do you
like to do in other words it says in
Psalm 37 he'll give you the desires of
your heart when you commit your life to
the Lord he will direct your paths he'll
put things on your heart God just began
to put it in my heart to preach and
that's how I kind of knew what he wanted
me to do is nothing nothing was bringing
me any more purpose or satisfaction than
telling other people how to live forever
so as you've committed yourself to the
Lord he directs your path talk to
Christian friends that you trust that
you know have a relationship with the
Lord and say what do you think my gifts
are what do you think God's plan is the
Bible tells us in the multitude of
counselors their safety so get some good
Christian counsel pray the god guy
and then look for providential openings
God's next step for you might be
shoveling sand in a golf course sandpit
that was one of his steps for me that
was his plan for me for at least one day
and then I realized that was not what I
was supposed to do with my whole life
but I had to do that for one day to know
that so don't be surprised if there's a
few detours Moses had to follow around a
bunch of sheep for several years before
he had this great work God put on him be
patient
so let me send you that book is that
okay fed nur it's called how do you
determine the will of God such a small
book but it's got all the Bible keys
anyone out there if you want to better
know what the god what God's will is for
your life or in some situation please
request this book we're sending it out
free we just trust people will continue
to support the ministry and we send this
stuff out by faith if you'd like to
receive that book that number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again just ask for the
book called determining the will of God
number one more time eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven does
your heart burns for a better purpose do
you yearn to do more with your faith do
you desire to be a powerful witness a
blaze for Jesus Christ where do you
start make your first step that F go the
amazing fact center of evangelism here
at Avco I've learned so many things in
my spiritual growth has just skyrocketed
fqo has distilled fifty years of amazing
facts evangelistic expertise into a
dynamic professional and educational
experience that transforms the nervous
Christian into a prepared and bold
witness Affco is really about learning
while doing it's a one-of-a-kind
experience for those who are serious
about entering gospel ministry and those
who simply want to make an impact in
their local churches and communities
go to ask org today and explore this
life-changing program Affco equipping
soul-winners setting the world ablaze
for God for life changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm or
call one eight hundred five three eight
seven two seven five our next caller
that we have let's see I think it's
sherry Ann listening from Massachusetts
sherry Ann welcome to the program hi hi
you both thank you also doing such a
wonderful job my question tonight is I
was reading God's Word and I came across
this two verses and in Exodus 12 40 says
now the sojourn of the children of
Israel who dwelled in Egypt was 430
years and in Genesis 15:13 says that he
said unto Abram no office no official II
think surely that thy seed shall be in
history in the land that is not theirs
and shall serve them and they shall
afflict them for four hundred years
so I was studying God's Word I mean you
know I don't want to be wrong and maybe
I misunderstand
somewhere along the line but I want to
understand is it the Israelites for
captivity in Egypt for 400 years of 400
cities well their captivity this is what
confuses people they were not in Egypt
for 400 anything years now there are two
different dates given if you look in
Genesis and you can look in Exodus and
even in Galatians 3:17 there seems to be
some confusion the 400 years is covering
the time from when God gave this warning
this prophecy to Abraham through the
Exodus that was 400 I think that's 430
years all the way through 1300 years in
Exodus 14 says 430 is but what I'm
getting at is the time they were
actually in Israel as slaves keep in
mind they didn't go right down and turn
into slaves they they weren't slaves
Joseph was 110 when he died in they
still weren't slaves so the slavery
itself
did not last I think it was closer to
200 years the period of time from the
time of prophecy that God gave Abraham
until the Exodus was I believe 430 years
but it depends on what your starting
point is is your starting point when he
gives him the prophecy or is it 30 years
later when Ishmael persecutes Isaac see
what I'm saying he he first gives him
the prophecy in Exodus and in Genesis 15
is that right yeah 15 13 and he says
know of a surety that your descendants
will be slaves in another country and
they'll serve them 400 years then if you
that time doesn't actually start from
when he gives them the prophecy 30 years
later when Ishmael is born and Ishmael
is persecuting I'm sorry 30 years later
after Isaac's born Ishmael is
persecuting Isaac Ishmael his mother was
an Egyptian they say this is when the
Egyptian persecution began I know that
sounds a little complex so there's a
30-year difference it's kind of coming
back to me as I share it with you from
when the prophecies given until the
persecution begins one is starting from
the prophecy to Abraham the other is
starting from the persecution of Ishmael
against Isaac the actual slavery in
Egypt didn't start until after Joseph
was dead and that's what around 200 and
that's closer to 200 we don't know the
exact date of the time that the Pharaoh
began to you know say I'm throwing the
babies in the river and making them
serve with hard labor it's kind of hard
to pin that down but that was closer to
200 years keep in mind that Moses
grandfather was a son of Levi Amram I
mean am Rams father there's a pretty
short span between the time of Levi who
went down to Egypt when he was live and
Moses so you got 200 years here so you
know I just I've seen several why you
and I have been talking to refresh my
memory I just typed in two Ghul
I'll admit it friends I just typed into
Google X to this four hundred thirty
years to find the articles that I've
read on that and you can see a lot of
great information on that cheery and
you're a good Bible scholar if you're
looking at those questions thanks so
much for your call
and hope that helps a little you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time call us at
[Music]
1-800-455-1052
many years following amazing facts
fantastic got a question when trying to
witness to a pastor a person with no
nothing not just a pastor a person with
a doctorate in theology and trying to
witness on key subjects of salvation all
truths how do you broach that subject
not being a person with those subjects
not being a person with a you know
studious but not with that type of
knowledge and you know these subjects
they had to have come up during the
teachers that they have received well I
don't want to dismiss the importance of
higher education you know Luther and
Paul were both very educated and their
education paid off in you know some some
great work that God did but then you
also have the world being turned upside
down by fishermen who had Jesus and the
Holy Spirit and the Word of God like
Peter and James and Andrew and as
Matthew Levi was an accountant so don't
I would never be intimidated by someone
who may have Apple if for a ssin of
degrees if you're studying with someone
they may be well studied and have
degrees if they're honest and humble if
they're proud of their degrees and they
probably stop learning if they're honest
and humble
unteachable yeah I've met some people
that went through college had all kinds
of degrees and they said you know we've
learned more from listening to amazing
facts than we learned in 30 years of a
church and universities so yeah and some
people they're just you know they're
only getting a small segment of the
truth so don't be intimidated by just
humbly pray and study with these people
and you know you also might do it in a
way where you ask questions you can
teach people by asking questions this is
what Jesus did with the scribes and the
Pharisees he got them to think by asking
questions how did he talk to Nicodemus
he talked about being born again yeah
you know Nicodemus was educated so hope
that helps a little bit yeah just
something of tugging at my heart and
I've been you know waiting for the
opportunity but you know that sense of
intimidation hey don't want to wrap
myself up without an answer without the
hope that is in me without being able to
answer it oh no you can do it and you've
got a good voice for radio I'll just
tell you yeah so I think that you keep
studying and you'll you'll go far
hey thanks so much for these we are said
yeah that's it and we appreciate your
call make fun of it we have is waste ly
listening from California waste a
welcome to the program yes my question
is what is there all the parents if
children are looking for this path for
the future grow more you know bright
what does the Bible teaches you know
like we have different cultures from
some cultures parents are more involved
in other in other cultures less but what
does the Bible teach how much parents
should be involved very good question I
actually dealt with that this week in
church if you read in the Bible when
Abraham's looking for a wife for Isaac
the parents traditionally had a very
large role you know now when kids are
young they ought to very carefully
listen to the input of their parents
they know them they know their strengths
and weaknesses sometimes others know us
better than we do and if kids would
often listen to their parents
advice when it comes to picking a mate
for life the voice of experience could
really guide them and sometimes save
them a lot of incompatibility and
anguish as young people get older if
they're young adults and they've got
their own job and they've got some
experience then you know it's always
nice to have you know people you're
interested in meet the family and get
your parents input but the older you get
the more self-sufficient you are more
mature you are the more independent you
would be in that decision the bible you
ask for Bible answer the parents you
know ours is reading this week when
Nehemiah said do not let your sons marry
pagan girls and do not let your
daughters marry pagan boys so the
parents evidently had a lot of saying
who the kids married back then because
they could prevent it but that doesn't
fly in some cultures right now you know
all the movies are about falling in love
and you see love at first sight and no
one ever listens to what does mom and
dad say anymore but it's not a bad idea
all right a lot of young people out
there think I'm crazy who's next pastor
Ross all right we go Maria listening in
California Maria you're on the line I
pastors how are you doing thank you and
your question tonight uh yeah my
question I've been reading the Book of
Ezekiel and the last area chapters is
talking about a temple and I'm confused
what kind of a temple they're talking
about he's talking about yeah it is
something of a mystery there are maybe
four or five temples mentioned in the
Bible there's the course the temple in
the wilderness there's a temple that was
built by Solomon
there's the temple that was rebuilt by
Nehemiah and Ezra there's the temple in
Revelation and then you've got this vast
temple that is described in the last
chapters of Ezekiel and Ezekiel's
prophecy that there are four prophets in
the Bible I might be missing one pastor
Ross but they're called apocalyptic
prophets that means they preach in
theirs their prophecies are full of
symbols revelation daniel zechariah and
ezekiel are some
the apocalyptic prophets that means not
everything they say is literal but
they're often symbolic Ezekiel is having
dreams and visions and there's ladies
that are carrying pots and things and
he's got a wheel within a wheel rolling
around with eyes in it and you're going
what does that mean it's not literal
so when Ezekiel talks about this Great
Temple and the River of Life flowing
from the temple some of that I think is
an allegory of what the nation of Israel
was to be Jesus said don't you know that
we are the temple of God the church and
that Jesus is the cornerstone and the
Apostle said we are being built up as
living stones in that temple and Christ
said destroy this temple made with hands
and in three days I will make one
without hands he spoke of his body so
here's this spiritual temple that is
spoken of in the New Testament
Ezekiel may have seen this temple with
the River of Life flowing as a symbol of
what was going to happen with God's
people taking the message of the gospel
to the world it may have been a symbolic
temple you got any thoughts on that
pastor Ross no I think you're right
pastor Dai I mean if perhaps if Israel
would have been faithful to God and God
was able to fulfill his full purpose
with Israel they could very well have
been this type of a temple there in
Jerusalem a Shinto float that's right
that was God's first plan for Israel
that there would be this great a
lighthouse of truth to the world yeah
and there's some similarity between
revelation and Ezekiel because in
Ezekiel in Revelation they're measuring
the temple mm-hmm and we know in
Revelation it's a symbol of God's people
mm-hmm anyway Maria I hope that helps a
little bit I do have a book I think
you'll enjoy and it's called spiritual
Israel and we talk about the spiritual
temple in there oh wait a second we got
a new sanctuary magazine we do maybe we
can send her one divine design yeah a
number to call if you'd like to receive
our brand new sanctuary magazine it's
called design divine design and we'll be
able to send this to to you Marie or
anyone who asks and this is one of our
premiere resources I think you'll really
enjoy it number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for divine design new
magazine on the sanctuary we've got a
caller from ala
Bama and let's see we have Alena who's
calling Lea Alena Alabama you Elena yes
welcome to the program hi and your
question tonight we got two minutes okay
my question is that I want to know okay
back in the Bible days how the angel
visited Mary and tell her that she's
gonna give birth to Jesus and but so
basically my question is I wanna ask is
the angel still visit God's people today
like they did back in the Bible days
yeah good questions is it possible for
angels to still visit people today
absolutely
you've got angels intermingling and
delivering messages all through the
Bible we know angels still exist the
Bible promises the angel of the lord
encamps around about those that fear Him
you have angels from Genesis to
Revelation these are the ministering
spirits they have not ceased to minister
now if someone says I saw an angel and
of course we're always suspicious
whether they really saw an angel or if
they you know had a dream but I don't
doubt that there are real people that
have had encounters I know one man I
really believe him just the Saint that
said that he was going to enter World
War one this is a long time ago and he
was praying about it while he was
praying in the cabin where he's praying
Olsson that was filled with light and
his angel appeared to him and said you
shall not go and he said you're to go to
college and study for ministry and it
disappeared and he just he describes it
and even when he describes it his face
glows I think he really saw an angel but
of course the Word of God is complete so
if someone says I've got a new message
from an angel angels aren't delivering
anything that's separate from the Word
of God now so you got to be careful
about that thank you for your question
we sure appreciate that we do have a
lesson about angel messages and we'll
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks the numbers 883 five six seven
four seven and again you can ask for the
lesson called angel messages and you'll
all join you'll enjoy that
Aliana friends were just about out of
time
I want to remind everybody that this
program you're hearing it only because
people like you say I'm being edified
and we want to keep it on the air would
you go to the amazing facts website you
can just click donate there send a
little something help us know you're
listening
we sure appreciate hearing from you god
bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts a faith-based ministry located in
Sacramento California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
divorce but that's when God led them to
an amazing fax broadcast and there they
saw the biblical view of marriage as
presented in knowing Jesus finally they
understood what it meant to love
sacrificially like Christ and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that you've
learned and it's easy to make a donation
just visit give dot amazing facts or RG
or send your gift to peel box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight you can also give us a call
at 877 five zero six one seven five one
the number again eight seven seven five
zero six one seven five one thank you
for tuning in to Bible answers live and
don't forget to share with others the
amazing Bible facts you have learned
here today written by the hand of God
and spoken with his
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com4 life-changing
Christian resources visit AF bookstore
calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
www.ge.com which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take
you